[Laughter]
[Music]
yes it's everyone's favorite kids movie
[Music]
what the hell am i doing joking aside we
have just a few days until the new
Netflix show the Dark Crystal age of
resistance comes out and I thought it
would be fun to take a deep dive into
this Jim Henson classic so get on your
land Striders because here we go
the main plot of the Dark Crystal is
quite simple a gelfling by the name of
Jen must save the world by reuniting the
Dark Crystal with it's missing shard you
see everything was great in the world
until the Dark Crystal was cracked a
thousand years ago this land was Green
and good until the crystal cracked the
cracking of the crystals spawn two new
races the Skeksis these vulture looking
creatures and the Mystics also known as
the ARU the Skeksis took control over
the crystal castle and dominated the
land killing anything that got in their
way including all the members of gems
raced the gelfling x' jen was lucky and
was saved by the Mystics however his
real journey begins with the death of
his master who tells him of a prophecy
that he needs to find the crystal shard
to save the world to save if he doesn't
the evil Skeksis will rule forever with
the death of Jen's master we learn a
little bit more about how the Skeksis
and mystics are intertwined when one of
the Skeksis dies so too does a mystic
they are inextricably linked it isn't
until the end of the movie that we see
this manifest but we'll get into that in
a bit
in the crystal castle the death of the
Emperor which coincided with the death
of Jen's master has left a power vacuum
to Skeksis that Chamberlain in the
general battle it out for superiority in
a ritual known as trial by stone in
which both characters beat the crap out
of a stone to see who can break it apart
the general is just too damn powerful
and as is Skeksis law the defeated
Chamberlain is stripped of his clothing
and ban
is this really a kids movie the crystal
summons the Skeksis which shows them an
image of a gelfling which shocks them to
no end because they thought they killed
the gelfling z-- ages ago and they know
that the prophecy States at gelfling
will destroy them speaking of prophecy
gen meets up with Oprah oh grow okra
anyway the woman he was sent to find who
may know the whereabouts of the missing
shard you see every thousand years the
three suns line up in an event known as
the great conjunction that's when the
crystal last cracked and the next
conjunction is almost here gen must make
sure the crystal is fully restored
before this event or could have
catastrophic consequences
Agra whose name sounds very similar to
augur an ancient Roman term for profit
or soothsayer shows genic collection of
glass shards which could be the one
needed for the crystal he uses his flute
because you know that's what you do
which resonates with the crystals
showing him which one to choose but just
as things are going well they're
attacked by the menacing Garthim the
Garthim are these scarab type creatures
who are under the command of the Skeksis
specifically the general who has now
become emperor around the same time the
mystics hear the call to Crystal and
begin their march to the castle for
their final stand Jen is able to escape
and bumps into another gelfling by the
name of kira this is strange for the
both of them since they both think
they're the last gelfling alive kira
like Jen was raised as an orphan after
her parents were killed by the Skeksis
but unlike Jen who was raised by the
Mystics cure was raised by the pod
Ling's the pod Ling's are these cute
creatures who are used by the Skeksis as
slaves and also drained of their living
essence by the scientist for the emperor
the Skeksis have devised this machine
using the crystal to drain creatures of
their living essence which is then drunk
by the emperor in order to make him
young again
there's only one problem puddling
essence
as strong as gelfling and only lasts a
few seconds if only there were some gyal
flings around to experiment on here
takes gen back to the pod ling village
where they have some Return of the Jedi
Ewok type celebration which is cut short
by another Garthim attack they're once
again able to escape but the toll of the
journey isn't sitting so well with gen
he throws the crystal shard away
lamenting about how it's caused him
nothing but trouble Kira gives him a pep
talk and retrieves the shard back to him
when they uncover what is known as the
house of the old ones
ancient gelfling ruins of their
ancestors it's here that Jen reads the
ancient prophecy on the wall let's break
it down
when single shines the triple Sun is
basically referring to how when the
three suns aligned during the great
conjunction they'll create a single beam
of light the next line what was sundered
and undone shall be hole refers to both
the crystal itself and the fusion of the
Skeksis and mystics both of these things
will be made whole in the final line the
two made one by Gil a hand or else by
none simply means that a gelfling will
do this or not at all this is the
prophecy Aughra and the Mystics referred
to but for our characters they still
don't quite know what it means yet Fura
calls on these weird-ass land Strider
creatures and they attack the Garthim in
order to save the captured pod Ling's
but the Garthim proved too strong and
Jen and Kira are pushed over the side of
a chasm but in a shocking twist Kira has
wings as she later tells Jen only female
gelfling have wings Jen and Kira are
able to find a hidden entrance into the
castle where they're attacked by the
Chamberlain the Chamberlain after having
been banished is looking for a way back
into the Emperor's good graces so
capturing a gelfling would be the
perfect gift Jen is trapped under some
rubble and Kira is brought to the mad
scientist where her essence will be
extracted but Kira has a
another special ability she's able to
communicate with animals she uses this
power to free the caged creatures who
are able to push the Skeksis scientist
into the lava core of the castle it's
here we get another reminder of how the
Skeksis and mystics are linked when the
Skeksis scientist dies here so too does
one of the Mystics jen emerges from the
rubble and climbs his way up to the main
chamber where the Skeksis have gathered
the great conjunction is about to happen
at any moment it's only with the help of
Kyra who's able to throw the crystal
shard to Jen in the nick of time
that jen is able to make the crystal
whole again but not without a cost Kyra
is stabbed by the Emperor the castle
starts to fall apart along with the
Garthim the Polling's regained their
life essence but it's only with the
arrival of the Mystics that the prophecy
is truly fulfilled the crystals beam
travels through the Mystics and into the
Skeksis compelling the Skeksis to merge
into the Mystics until they become
something entirely new the prophecy is
fulfilled these beings here are known as
the fallen Earth's kkuk who are banished
from their homeworld during the last
conjunction in their attempt to purify
themselves through the power of the
great crystal they inadvertedly divided
themselves into two separate beings the
violent materialistic Skeksis and the
gentle contemplative mystics
but what is most apparent here is the
symbolism of good combining with evil
how we all have the capacity to swayed
toward the light or dark the Earth's
Keck are the physical representation of
this but also of our own humanity we can
be violent and materialistic but also
kind and compassionate at the end of the
day it's up to us who we want to be
embrace bravery kindness and courage
like Jen or jealousy materialism and
violence like the Chamberlain
is part of you as we all know part love
each other with the crystal restored in
the prophecy fulfilled the earth
Coquille Kira so that Jen and Kira can
make the world in the crystal of truths
light the crystal of truth is the same
thing as the Dark Crystal just in a
different form
the crystals origin dates back to the
formation of thraw the land this story
takes place in it was the crystal who
created augur to act as the voice and
eyes of the rocks and the trees a way
for it to communicate to them but during
the first great conjunction the earth
cux used the beam of light to travel
from their planet to thraw for a
thousand years that Earth's qeq ruled
tearing down the mountains surrounding
the crystal and building the castle
around it which we see this crystal
castle at the end of the movie they
ruled much better than the Skeksis
bringing new technology to the world and
for the most part getting along with all
of its inhabitants it wasn't until this
second great conjunction when the
Earth's cux wanted to purify themselves
of their darker nature that the crystals
split apart causing what's known as the
great division that's how we get these
Skeksis and the Mystics but some of you
are probably wondering how all this fits
into the new Netflix show the Dark
Crystal Age of resistance age of
resistance is a prequel to the Dark
Crystal set many years before the events
of the film it follows three gelfling 's
who inspire a rebellion against the
Skeksis when they discover a horrifying
secret behind their power that threatens
the world of thraw this matches up with
what we've learned from the movie both
kira and jen believe themselves to be
the last of the Gelf things but in the
trailers we see the entire gelfling
civilization before the war with the
Skeksis it's a bit bittersweet to watch
a show where we know the outcome is the
gelfling 'he's losing but my guess is
that the writers will have a way around
this regardless the trailers are
chock-full of new creatures and old like
agra the land Striders the crystal
castle and even pod Ling's I hope you'll
join me when age of resistance comes out
as I'm planning to do a video covering
the entire season so make sure to LIKE
and subscribe with a bell on and give me
your thoughts on the movie below you can
follow me on twitter at think story
whitey and remember daddy loves you very
much